willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung in der
die uns mit carl christian schmid ja
nordkreuz auseinandersetzen werden
da sind seitdem hat die auch sehr
unbekannt sind die aber doch einige
aufmerksamkeit verdienen den ersten
dinge möchte ich kurz vorstellen dass es
gar christian schmid und er hat eine
schrift verfassten der titel versuch
einer moralphilosophie gegen zweiter
auflage erschienen 1790 und sitze
92 was gibt es eine person zu sagen wenn
die arbeit zeitgenosse eines anderen
denkt nämlich leonard kreuz als das ist
auch so gut wie unbekannt und er hat
eine schrift verfasst in dem titel
skeptische betrachtung über die freiheit
des winds mit den sich auf dem
juristentag über dieselbe noch mal
zurück zu carl christian schmid und
seine versuche eine philosophie er war
ein ganz wichtiger verbreitet der kanton
philosophie jena jeder war damals das
zentrum der partie an
und er schrieb ein wörterbuch sind
leichter gebrauchte kannst schriften wir
jetzt viele auflagen fuhr und für die
damalige generation zu sagen das
studienbuch war mit dem sie sich
gigantische philosophie erschließen
kommt dieses lexikon verlinke ich auch
unten in der beschreibung des videos
damit man sich herunterladen kann
für die provokative theorie eines dem
fatalismus gegen die in der folge unter
anderem reinhold wichtig stehen und mit
2 mit diesem internet dem fatalismus und
in der heutigen sitzung kurz gefasst er
schreibt nämlich folgendes in seinem
versuch einer moralphilosophie ich
zitiere wenn wir keine 5000 zufall
einräumen wollen so bleibt nichts übrig
als eine notwendigkeit ist
schlechterdings keinen mittelweg
zwischen 1
das musste man etwas als vorhanden
gedacht werden was zugleich mit dem
dasein ihre wirksamkeit auf den scheiben
und bestimmten geht diesmal neben gratis
er bestimmt dieses freilich kaum
erschrecken dem eine entscheidung kann
kein team hat sich selbst bestimmen wenn
aber gleich die sinnlichkeit so wie sie
selbst sich vor gestritten erkannt wird
ansicht nicht einschränkt kann so folgt
aus keineswegs dass das wenige was das
wirklichkeit in allen ihren der scheiben
und sich zugrunde liegt und von irgend
zwei die wirkung der von der stadt aus
einzuschränken
wir haben jetzt ein ganz wichtiges die
tat zwar haben wir es jetzt hier zu tun
mit diesem interview dem fatalismus der
besagt dass die vernunft selbst eine
wieder rettet er die nation besitzt und
uns unausweichlich bestimmt wenn wir
frei sind weil nach steht es kein
indifferent ist es gibt keinen mittelweg
zwischen determination und zu fall und
daran sehen wir das auch an ulrich
anknüpft nicht nach oben rechts und
links ulrich hat genau eine ähnliche
theorie vertreten
der integrierte fatalismus das ist eine
theorie auf die sich schmid deswegen
beziehen kann war kant an vielen stellen
die vernunft als etwas dargestellt hatte
was lange wirksam ist und was wenn es
nicht handelt irgendwelche intelligent
hinderungsgründe besitzen muss
und das war eine eigenständige
weiterführung gigantischen theorien
bewusster zu sagen grad keine tg voerde
fatalismus
aber man kann diesen fatalismus aus
seiner theorie reduzieren wenn man sich
etwas abschnitt jetzt noch zu klären
seien skeptisch betrachten die fall des
links diese skeptischen betrachtung
resultieren aus der damaligen debatten
lage geradezu schreiben allein welche
achtung gleiten hier für mich und jedes
andere endlich gewesen bricht wenn meine
fragen komplett wendigkeit ist wo er auf
die folgen zu sehen die aus den
unternehmen in fatalismus so gut erstens
hinter terrorismus positive gesetzgebung
unter weiter hergeleitet werden kann
also schreibt mehr nach uns als
bisherige und das sind nur zwei wege für
uns offen entweder gegen terrorismus
oder fatalismus die erste da ebenso
wenig mit dem gesetz in der
theoretischen als unterforderung der
praktischen vernunft sein
denn jetzt hingegen sei irrsinn völlig
gemäss scheint aber den letzten durchaus
zu sprechen und jetzt kommt dazu einem
ziel dramatisch ist eine allegorie
gerade diese gefährlichen stellen
scheinen die großen männer das ja und
jetzt die redlichen zu 100 forscher
mitten auf dem ozean menschlicher man
sich selbst zu überlassen
schon mancher nicht geringen gefahr
durch höhe für das bisschen kompasses
und der neuen karten kann die aber eine
dem unsterblichen stiften der kritischen
philosophie das ist verdammt scheint mir
weder karte nach kompass zu helfen
er mag steuern auf welcher seite er will
sich haben
und doch scheint auch das stelle stehen
die skeptische demokratisch bewegt also
auch kreuzes und der damaligen debatte
eine gewisse aporie wir können nicht
vorankommen
wir haben nur die wahl zwischen freiheit
und notwendigkeit so ein letztes zitat
von ihm ebenso eben so sehr verachtet
ihren bewusstsein seiner menschlichen
würde den rat derjenigen die ihn von
allen seiten her zu rufen das knie dazu
gegen unseren schiffchen den werden und
winkten zum spiel zu erlassen noch immer
mehr die gründe nach beiden seiten sagt
allein das ist ein traum bleibt
die praktische vernunft scheint in der
theoretischen spekulativen durchaus
vereinbar zu sein
dennoch würde er verrichtet ihres den
vorzugeben aber ihre ansprüche
erschweren die mal rasch ein
gefährlicher als unbefriedigend für sie
zu sein einen absoluten zu folgt oder
eine absolute notwendigkeit die moral
stadtregierung die hände zu geben
jetzt sehen wir große sagt wir können
die beiden anforderungen erkannt
derartige freiheit fordern und der
spekulativen die alles determiniert und
erklärt ihr könnt nicht miteinander
vereinbar
die freiheit scheint in dem satz es zu
reichen kunden nicht vereinbar zu sein
und deswegen haben wir jetzt hier die
schlechte wahl
alles nur zufall oder eine absolute
notwendigkeit und heraus epics ein
skeptizismus das ist durchaus eine
situation die auch um die gegenwärtige
debatte in verbindung gebracht haben
kann auch in der heutigen debatte haben
wir viel freiheit skeptiker dieser
freiheit ist nicht mit der natur
gesetzlich gehalten verbunden
der unterschied besteht darin dass
heutzutage die debatte wird am besten
vor allem der naturwissenschaft
argumentieren wäre damals sind die
journalisten vor allem die zahlreiche
gründe ist oder auch mit der moralisch
moralische notwendigkeit im siegerland
das internet den fatalismus eine art von
determinismus vertragen so jetzt wünsche
ich meinen zuschauern den zuschauer
alles gute und vor weihnachten